after bringing the story of the
Guardians of the Galaxy to a triumphant
end James Gunn fully takes his place in
the DCU but what does he think about the
potential for a volume 4 of his iconic
movies spoilers ahead prior to the
release of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. it seemed all but certain that writer
and director James Gunn would kill off
one of the central Heroes after all the
creative Maverick hasn't been afraid to
kill off fan favorite characters in the
past so why would he stop now luckily
volume 3 spares the ragtag Galaxy
hopping group giving each individual
member a satisfying send-off while the
threequel wraps up gun's tenure with
Marvel a team like the Guardians lent
itself to countless iterations with new
characters with that in mind could we
see a Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 4 One
Day Gunn told Esquire Middle East I
don't think there will ever be a
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 4. there's
many reasons this group will not be back
there could be more Guardians movies but
it won't be with this group I want you
all to know I'm grateful to fight beside
my friends although he'll be working
full-time spearheading the DC Universe
moving forward Gunn isn't against the
idea of someone else tackling another
version of the Guardians team under one
condition he said I think as long as
somebody brings themselves to it and
doesn't just try to copy that style I
think it can be really amazing and
there's so many directors I would like
to do that and I would love to see it
happen
those who have seen volume 3 will know
that the initial post-credit sequence
sets up a brand new Guardians team with
Rocket Raccoon as their leader while it
remains to be seen if the Guardians
teased at the end of the film will ever
headline their own sequel it's possible
that any number of characters from the
comics could make the jump to the big
screen Nova Hercules hulkling and Wiccan
recently worked together in the comics
as Guardians as well with each of these
characters either already in the MCU or
on the way it's possible that they could
lead a guardian's Revival down the line
if Marvel Studios ever wants to launch a
team that's drastically different from
the one in guns films they could lean
into a number of markedly weirder
versions that appear throughout the
Guardians Comics although these might
require some drastic setup different
versions of the Guardians have included
Kitty Pride Agent Venom Beta Ray Bill
Cosmic Ghost Writer thing and even
Doctor Doom leaving plenty of room for
Marvel to experiment should a fourth
Guardians film ever come to pass
volume 3 ends with a bold claim the
legendary Star-Lord will return the
movie wraps up with Peter Quill hanging
out with his grandfather this tease
however suggests that Quill's time on
Earth isn't permanent and that it's
possible that he'll return to the cosmos
prior to the film's release Chris Pratt
expressed interest in returning as Peter
he told Rolling Stone practically can
Peter Quill come back the answer will
always be yes now if you're saying to me
Chris Pratt the actor do I want to
reprise my role as Peter Quill and is
there mileage left in the character and
do I have the bandwidth or headspace for
that I do I'd be interested in playing
the character again
gun in a tweet that has since been
deleted described Guardians 3 as the
last Guardians movie for most of us
further suggesting the series possible
continuation with at least some legacy
cast seeing as volume 3 ends on an open
note it's all but likely that audiences
will have more Guardians of the Galaxy
in the future it just won't be volume 4.
foreign